hey guys this is andrew for trading
census.com i've been working as a
professional trainer for the past six
years in hong kong
and i'm doing youtube videos right now
because
guys i want to share my experience i
want to show you
how i do my analysis how portrait is
actually working
what kind of tools and techniques we use
to make money on the markets
so if you want to know about all this
stuff and see how we develop our views
and set up our trains
you are in the right place so today i
want to make an update on the weed
stocks
so i'm gonna pick up chili and sundale
because they are for me the two
most hot stocks and make an analysis on
it
let's get into it
[Music]
so let's start with sundial what can we
see just first
technically then we're going to quickly
go to the news technically i did a video
on this one guys
i was saying that 120 was a nice
support level i was saying don't buy it
here guys like i always say
don't formal guys don't buy those
breakouts that are crazy if you miss it
it's
fine there are many opportunities go to
the most likely ones
where you can set up trades with tight
stop losses so here we
we had one of those opportunity so on
the daily time frame
you can see so sundial just went crazy
up
and then came back so guys here it was a
resistance level
you can see guys quite easy to spot
those horizontal
resistance or support levels are easy to
spot the most recent it is the better it
is
and you need to find where you had some
reactions in the past
so here one two this one is not clear
all right
i can put it here i can put it here but
look the most recent past
where was the resistance guys where was
actually the area
where cells were uh increasing their
positions it was at 1 20.
so then i tried to find something that
fits the best so this one is a bit high
so i go here so this is my support level
128 and what happened
so a few days ago guys you can see i'm
not sure like
which day i'm going to release this
video maybe i'm going to receive a few
days so i might have a bit of a lag
but uh i do it on the 25th of february
in hong kong so this is like the u.s
session overnight
24th of february so what we can see guys
is that we had
the support level that got broken quite
bad guys you can lose here 30
so you know that's why where you put
your stop loss is very important
so you have yeah around 15 20 so
you know for those penny stocks i like
to take 20 30
as a stop loss and here once again guys
you buy
you could get stop plus it depends on
how big is your stop-loss
but if you're not getting stopped then
you don't have the second consecutive
candle below the breakout level
so it's no reason to change your trade
then you have this nice rebound guys so
this support has been tested
not broken and now guys this is a very
small move
this is only 15 up guys i expect
much more to come where are our next
resistance level so here of
course this is one obvious resistance
level you see guys i was checking here
and here and this is how i found this
one so
of course this one happened already but
it's going to be the new one
but guys once a resistance has been
tested once twice
three times it gets weaker and usually
it gets overcome
so here i expect the price to come back
at this levels so around 200 percent
so once again you can make 200 guys be
ready to study
it's like one two six risk reward ratio
it's very
good so guys very important logarithmic
scale for the staff very important
otherwise you won't understand what i'm
doing you're gonna try to do the same
go on trading view it's free i mean i
have the pro account but for the
free account you have a lot of tools you
can use already and try to do some
shot on the license like i do so here
another thing you can do
you check the moving averages you go on
the hourly time frame and you can find
a level to enter so for now we are
trading below the 200 period moving
average that's why the price action is
contained
but things are going to change uh you
see the breakout
occurred here guys so i'm trying to find
the one that is feeding the the best
and guys look what i had here so now
it's green so i didn't go
on the shorter time frame when i did it
last time right
right now i'm doing it and you can see
here we have this bearish trend
that was resistance here consolidation
we break out we re-test it and guys it's
like a double
support level you you had the uh support
level
done by the uh downward sloping trend
line that was
uh on the uh short time frame and on the
longer time frame
we saw that 128 was a strong support and
guys
it got broken here and then re-tested so
it didn't go to 128 it went to
134 but guys this is approximative
numbers
and right now we are pushing higher so
maybe we're gonna have one more re-test
but to me this is ready we had this
consolation here that took place for uh
uh quite a long time
so i expect something like this so maybe
this is a bit too bullish because guys
look at the short interest
so this could happen if you have a short
squeeze without short squeeze
it's hard guys to get such a strong
moves up
let's check uh the short interest on the
stuff
so i go on market watch as i told you
guys here
is actually the schedule of the release
of the new short interest
and the last one was january 29th
it was very controversial different
websites have different data
now the 12th of february has been
released yesterday guys on wednesday
this is the release date i'm going to
put this in the
description of the video so you can be
able to go and check it by yourself
this is true for all the stocks all
right the u.s stocks
so now on market watch it's updated
so let's have a look at sender
sndl okay data of 12th of february
you can trust this then have a look at
the total public float it must be close
to the outstanding shares
here you have 50 difference so i'm not
100 sure
the public float is not bigger usually
it's very close to this
the difference between the public floats
which is the shares available for
training
and outstanding shares is only the
insider shares so
shares owned by people who actually
manage the company so it's usually very
close especially for those markets cap
around 1 billion so i think the public
float might be underestimated here
and so we have at least maximum of 10
shares that are shielded amongst the
available shares so this is telling me
guys
that if the price is going higher and
hedge funds consider that
the stock is overvalued they're going to
show it all right because as charlie
mundler said
as long as [ __ ] can be sold we're going
to keep selling [ __ ]
sorry for my language but this is
exactly his words and
he's saying this because you know hedge
funds are here to actually control
if there is any mismanagement in the
company you think guys that this is not
good but actually it's kind of healthy
to have like you know people who work
hard to actually
check if the job is done properly and if
there is no mismanagement if there is
they're going to show the company you
can think it's not
moral but i think that it brings some
balance in
the finance industry which in some
way is good so anyway what i'm saying is
that
if the price action goes at levels that
make the stock of the value
they're going to keep shorting it so
careful guys uh 10
of short interest means the short
squeeze is
less likely to happen even impossible
right you need 30 40 percent
for those market caps uh
quickly let's go t to chile so it's a
bit the same story guys
uh so i'm not gonna explain in detail
how i found my
levels so resistance resistance so 54
is the next resistance level same thing
guys here the maximum level here the
maximum level here
all right so this was our support level
it got touched two days ago so guys i
was
telling you here it's a nice level to
buy and
you would have get this trade down if
you buy it here and stop lost 20 30
below and now guys it's probably gonna
move higher some bullish
on sndl and bullish until ray if we stay
above
those support levels so let's quickly
check the
short interest on children guys
updated 12th of february same stuff 18
it's a bit more so here a short quiz is
more likely to happen
so just keep this in mind guys so that's
it for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video i hope you know
where to find your data and how to
actually use it to you know
use the market dynamics knowing for
example to shoot interest
and to use the support and resistance
levels in the good way
so if you did please don't forget to
click the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys